bienvenu merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors pas de terme
séparatisme dans ce nouveau projet de
loi pourquoi et n'ont ni séparatisme ni
laïcité ne sont mentionnés dans ce
nouveau projet de loi comme s'il ne
fallait surtout pas parler du loup
pourquoi sans doute pour éviter de
froisser le conseil constitutionnel ou
bien faire que ce projet de loi soit
encore une fois de la communication
politique plus qu'aucune réelle action
pour lutter contre le séparatisme
islamique tel qu'il avait été pourtant
définies dans les discours des modèles
macron et de gérald darmanin
donc on peut se poser la question de la
réelle volonté derrière ce projet de loi
qui est une liste à la prévert un
d'action pour renforcer le contrôle sur
les associations mais aussi la façon
dont les associations qui gèrent les
mosquées devraient faire montre de
transparence financière
l'interdiction de scolariser les enfants
à domicile à partir de 3 ans enfin toute
une série de mesures finalement qui
semble cosmétiques comparé à la menace
réelle du terrorisme islamique
alors une loi qui propose un contrôle
renforcé des associations vous le dire
est ce que selon vous la loi de 1901
n'est plus suffisante aujourd'hui dont
la loi de 1901 est tout à fait
suffisantes et ce qui est inquiétant ce
n'est pas qu'il fasse en force et le
contrôle des associations c'est
nécessaire à partir du moment où elles
touchent de l'argent public et où elle
aurait un objet qui serait contraire aux
soi-disant valeurs de la république ou
qui seraient potentiellement dangereux
mais aucune personne ne va constituer
une association en déclarant qu'elle va
ouvertement faire oeuvre de séparatisme
ou quoi que ce soit donc je ne vois pas
comment ce contrôle pourrait se faire ça
c'est la première question qui mérite de
qu'on s'y attarde
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que non
seulement on veut revenir sur cette loi
de d'associations mais eric dupond
moretti a montré aussi un certain
empressement à vouloir revenir sur la
loi de 1881 qui régit la liberté
d'expression et la liberté de la presse
est là c'est extrêmement dangereux parce
que cette loi est très bien faite elle
fait que nous sommes dans le cadre d'une
démocratie libérale
or on voit bien que derrière il ya une
volonté qui n'est pas celle de protéger
les citoyens contre les discours de
haine mais plutôt d'empêcher les
journalistes
journaliste citoyen de faire leur
travail c'est ce qu'il a dit d'ailleurs
devant le sénat en dix ans certains
utilisent cette loi pour se loger
derrière la loi de 180 je trouve que là
c'est la ligne rouge qui ne doit pas
être franchie parce que ça voudrait dire
à partir du moment où cette loi est
abrogée à bander revu que nous ne sommes
plus dans le cadre d'une démocratie
libérale mais que nous allons avoir une
loi de censure a priori c'est à dire
avant même de pouvoir prendre la parole
ou immédiatement après la prise de
parole se retrouver devant une cour de
justice est là nous tombons dans un
autre régime que celui que nous
connaissons ce qu'il ya un risque avec
ce nouveau projet de loi qui à l'étude
il ya un risque en fait avec tous les
projets de loi actuellement à l'étude
qui sont finalement en train de dessiner
les contours d'un nouveau régime
extrêmement liberticide potentiellement
autoritaire et est loin finalement des
rivages de la démocratie libérale telle
que je venais de l'expliquer ou la prise
de parole est libre et sanctionner a
posteriori
là on a un gouvernement qui veut
l'ascension les façons sur les réseaux
sociaux dans la rue dans les colonnes
des journaux et dans les associations
dans les rassemblements on a
l'impression finalement que ce
confinement a accéléré la volonté
liberticide du gouvernement je trouve
extrêmement et comme hypocrite de parler
d'une loi sur les principes républicains
alors que les principes de la république
sont foulées aux pieds quotidiennement
par là la pratique du pouvoir en conseil
de défense derrière des lieux clos par
la répression des manifestations
pourtant déclaré avec à déchets demande
aux forces canons à eau
toujours le lb des les coups de matraque
tout ça est devenu quasiment quotidiens
et le fait de vouloir y compris les
mouvements lycéens qui ont été
sévèrement réprimées et derrière avoir
cette hypocrisie volontaire de parler de
principes républicains on a là affaire à
une manipulation de grande ampleur ou
une hypocrisie qui moi me choque
selon-vous l'arsenal législatives qui
actuellement en vigueur en france est
suffisant pour lutter contre ce qui est
appelé l'islam radical l'islam politique
il est suffisant en partie oui
regardez simplement les annonces de
gérald darmanin de reconduite aux
frontières si on mettait en place les
obligations de quitter le territoire
français
réellement il parlait de 200 plus de 150
profils de fichiers radicaliser s
condamné qui aurait dû être accompagné à
la frontière nous n'avons pas les
chiffres du nombre qui ont été
réellement raccompagner à la frontière
et dans ce projet de loi sur les
principes républicains
plutôt que de raccompagner à la
frontière ceux qui ont des discours de
haine qui encourage le terrorisme est
bien là on va simplement les interdire
de lieux de culte pour que les prêcheurs
de haine ne puisse plus prêcher dans
l'est dans les lieux de culte
voyez déjà comment on rétrécit et c'est
pour ça que je parle de mesures
cosmétiques alors que le droit existe
les lois existent mais gérald darmanin
ne les appliquent pas il fait comme le
reste du gouvernement d effet d'annonce
de la communication politique mais il ne
joue pas son rôle de ministre et
aujourd'hui alors que la menace est bien
réelle
on voit bien que beaucoup trop
d'annoncés est encore une fois très peu
d'actes et là ça devient critique
ça commence à se voir alexis poulain
remercie d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes
merci